[Music]
as many Cleveland sports fans will
remember NBA superstar LeBron James took
his talents to South Beach in 2010 only
to return to Cleveland in 2014 in a new
paper Cleveland born Danny show again I
look at with LeBron Jews between Miami
and Cleveland meant for the economies of
each state we looked at the number of
bars and restaurants within a mile of
the American Airlines Arena in Miami and
the Quicken Loans Arena in Cleveland and
then compared years in which LeBron was
present two years in which he was not
now when LeBron is around there are 13%
more bars and restaurants and they
employ a little under 25 percent more
people to ensure that this is indeed a
LeBron effect and not simply the results
of citywide booms and busts we check
what happens farther out not much it
turns out this confirms our suspicions
that's four superstars can indeed have a
noticeable economic impact that that
impact is very low-key these effects are
greater in Cleveland than they are in
Miami and that is a clear indication
that LeBron should not have left in the
first place to read our full paper on
the LeBron effect check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds